europe's biggest economy is poised to
re-enter
lockdown german chancellor angela merkel
is meeting with regional leaders today
to discuss the path forward as
some researchers say germany is facing a
third wave of coronavirus infections
the country has registered almost 8 000
new
daily cases of the virus that makes
germany's first wave
infections a year ago look relatively
small
although fewer tests were being carried
out back then
well the numbers fell back over the
summer but they began to
rise again in the fall leading to a much
bigger second wave
and by late december there were four
times the number of
infections recorded in april stronger
lockdown measures brought those numbers
down again but since the start of march
there has been
another sharp rise in infections
scientists fear
cases could jump to another new high
well chancellor mackel and regional
leaders will be weighing
health risks and potential damage to the
economy when they begin their talks
in a few hours from now our political
correspondent thomas sparrow
is covering those talks today he joins
us now thomas
a worrying rise in infections here in
germany as the chancellor meets
state premiers again what measures are
they
looking at it is certainly
worrying terry because only a few weeks
ago
german leaders had met to plan how
germany would
reopen those plans actually included a
so-called
emergency break in other words how they
would roll back
those opening steps if infections rose
again
and judging by numbers here in germany
judging by infections judging by the
fact
that now we're seeing exponential growth
again it is very probable that
authorities
will tighten the screws again of that
lockdown here in germany and we will see
further restrictions further
restrictions terry
which by the way are affecting
businesses across
germany who were already very worried
about the situation
let's look at the report that we
produced about one of those businesses
that's particularly affected
this homemade chocolate cherry cake is a
favorite with customers
at the moment figo lemke can only serve
it to go
but that doesn't cover her costs at all
by now she's accumulated a debt of
around 35 000 euros
if germany were to decide on a third
hard lockdown she'd be forced to close
if a third lockdown is actually put in
place then i would definitely have to
shut down for good
because i've taken out two loans which
i'll have to pay back
uh
many businesses in germany fear for
their existence
some have already given up meanwhile
covet cases in the country are
increasing rapidly
just weeks after restrictions were eased
and schools and some shops reopened
more people are on the move exposing
themselves to the risk of infection
researchers warned germany's vaccination
rollout has not progressed enough to
counteract this
even if we've already vaccinated many of
the elderly
there's still a large proportion of
vulnerable people who have not been
given the jab
that's why the number of patients in
intensive care units will rise again
many people in germany are torn at the
prospect of a third lockdown
i'm not thrilled because it's been going
on for a year now and at some point
you're really done with it all
with alum i'd rather be open and just
live
it's boring there are many coveted cases
now
[Music]
that means many businesses will go bust
figo lemka still hopes to avoid
bankruptcy she still wants to sell her
homemade cakes for many years to come
thomas people here in germany are
understandably frustrated at the slow
rollout of the vaccination campaign is
there any sign that that
vaccination rollout is going to get
faster
terry there's no doubt that there's
frustration at germany's very slow
vaccination
rollout in fact a vast majority of
germans believe
it's not going the way it should it's
going badly or
very badly and that's why authorities
have been trying to speed up
that vaccination program one of the key
areas that they're focusing now
on is involving some of the gps or
family doctors who could then help to
administer
some of those very important coronavirus
vaccines
for those who are expecting this to
speed everything up very quickly
they will probably be disappointed but
it's not only about speed here
it's also about flexibility on the one
hand that's something that they expect
to achieve
by involving gps and family doctors and
on the other hand
as well it's about trust which has been
damaged
in the last few weeks and which
authorities also hope
can be restored with the help of family
doctors who know
their patients very well so these are
the elements that authorities are
focusing now on
when it comes to making sure that this
all-important vaccination
rollout can actually happen better and
quicker
you mentioned trust thomas this is also
affecting germany's health minister yen
span he's under scrutiny for a
mass procurement contract tell us more
about that
that's correct the deal involves uh the
health ministry
and the company for which jens spann's
husband actually
works and we're talking here about the
procurement of face masks although both
the ministry
and the company involved have rejected
any wrongdoing but it comes on top
of problems that angela merkel's
conservatives are already facing
for possible corruption involving the
by buying and selling of face masks so
we're talking here about
not only all these problems that we've
discussed but also a very politically
difficult moment for angela merkel's cdu
csu block here in germany
thomas thank you very much our political
correspondent thomas sparrow there
you